So far we've seen how to examine a variables
distribution using histograms, and how to check our hunches
with visualizations and numerical summaries. But there's another type
of plot that let's us compare distributions, and it's called
the frequency polygon. Frequency polygons are similar to histograms,
but they draw a curve connecting the counts in
a histogram. So this allows us to see the
shape and the peaks of our distribution in more detail.
You might remember from before that we were looking at
friend count using this code. This code gives a histogram of
our user's friend counts, and then we added a facet wrap
and broke it out by gender. Remember we were trying to
answer the question, who on average has more friends, men or
women. We said we couldn't tell based on this histogram, so
we ran some numerical summaries instead. And instead of having these
2 histograms side by side, we can actually use a frequency
polygon and overlay these histograms together. Here's how we can
create that frequency polygon. I'll copy and paste the same code,
except I need to make an addition. By default q plot's
going to create a histogram when I pass it just one single
variable. So I need to tell it to create a frequency
polygon instead. I can use the geom parameter to do that.
Here, I'll pass it frequency polygon, so that way we create
a different type of plot, and I won't need this facet
wrap by gender anymore. To get the distributions of each
gender on the plot, I'm going to pass the parameter color
to q plot and set it equal to gender. So
here's my color parameter, and now I'm going to pass it gender.
When I run this code, I get one plot with
2 frequency polygons one for males and one for females. And
notice how gender has been assigned a color, so color
is indicating which frequency polygon I'm on. And this is what
the frequency polygon is really good for. We can compare
2 or more distributions at once, but again, this plot
doesn't really answer our question who has more friends on
average men or women. Let's change the y-axis to show
proportions instead of raw counts. This is going to involve
some funky syntax, so I want to explain it. To
change this count variable, we're going to pass in y
to our q-plot function. I'm going to assign the parameter y
this expression. This allows me to get proportions instead of the
actual raw counts on the y-axis. And I'm just move this
around so that way my code looks a little bit cleaner.
And finally, let me change the labels to more accurately explain the
plot. Alright, it looks like I have everything. Let's run this
code and see the differences. Zooming in on the plot, we can
see that we've changed the y-axis scale, and we have our
labels appearing here and here. And while it may appear that males
have higher friend counts on average than women, we can
see that many males or a high percentage of them have
low friend counts. It's probably in this tail region of the
graph where females overtake males. I encourage you to play around
with this yourself in RStudio to see where women overtake
men in this side of the x-axis. Try using limits or
try using breaks to explore more. We've learned some new syntax
here, so let's see if you can put it into practice.
Your task is to determine which gender creates more
likes on the world wide web. To answer that
question, I want you to create a frequency polygon
and explore it in many different ways. Remember that
the first plot that you make doesn't need to
be final. I want you to create a couple
of plots and make adjustments to the limits and
the breaks on the x axis until you're satisfied.